thank you
two years ago i stood on the third stage
in arusha tanzania
i spoke very briefly about of one my
proudest creation
it was a simple machine that changed my
life
before that time
i had never
been away from my home
in malawi
i had never used a computer i had never
seen an internet
on stage that day i was so noticed
my english lost
i wanted to vomit
i had never
been surrounded by so many azungo
white people
there was a story i couldn't tell you
then but well
i'm feeling good right now i'd like to
share that story today
we are seven children in my family
all sisters accepting me
this is me with my dad when i was a
little boy
before i discovered the wonders of
science i was just a simple farmer in a
country of poor farmers
like everyone else with groomers
one year our fortune turned very bad
in 2001 we experienced an awful famine
within five months
all malawians began to starve to death
my family
ate one meal per day at night
only three swallows of simmer for each
one of us
the food passes through our bodies
we drop down to nothing
in malawi
secondary school you have to pay school
fees
because of the hunger i was forced to
drop out of school
i looked at my father and looked those
dry fields
it was the future i couldn't accept
i feel very happy to be at the festival
of secondary school
so
i was determined to do anything possible
to receive education
so i went to a library
i learned books science books especially
physics
i couldn't read english that well i use
diagrams and pictures to learn the words
around them
another book put that knowledge in my
hands
it said
windmill
could pump water
and generate electricity
pump water meant irrigation a defense
against hunger
which were experiencing by that time
so i decided i'll build one windmill for
myself
but i didn't have materials to use
so i went to a scrap yard
where i found my materials
many people
including my mother
said i was crazy
i found a tractor fan
shock exuber pvc pipes
using a bicycle frame
and the old bicycle dynamo
i built my machine
it was one light at first
and then
four lights
with switches
and even a circuit breaker modded after
an electric bill
another machine
pumps water
for irrigation
kills of people start lining up at my
house
to charge their mobile phone
i could not get rid of them
and the reporters came to
which led to blood gas
and which led to a call from something
called ted
i had never seen an airplane before had
never slept in a hotel
so
on stage that day in elusia
my english lost
i said something like
i tried
and i made it
so i'd like to say something
to all the people out there
like me to the africans
and the poor
who are struggling with your dreams
god bless
maybe one day
you watch this on the internet
i said to you
trust yourself
and believe
whatever happened don't give it up
thank you
so
ah
you